reports suggest that Trump will skip the
first few Republican primary debates
because he is leading his competitors
are trailing and he is scared of being
up there on the stage for two hours in
an uncontrolled environment with a group
of people who are growing uh gunning for
him while Trump supporters think in
terms of wrestling and believes that
attacking Trump will hurt their chances
the presidency requires a fight and
Trump should be challenged like any
other candidate Republicans who are soft
Trump supporters need to begin to see
that the American people won't let that
man back in the white house because of
the fraudulent attempts to subvert the
election culminating in the violent uh
overrunning of the U.S capital most of
those around Trump know his problems
such as bad judgment little
understanding of history and disordered
ego they're for him for their own
reasons and believe that the Democrats
and the media are worse what are your
thoughts on this and what's going to
happen with debates I think
there's no reason to debate anybody he's
a big dog who's pulling at the top but I
think uh maybe afraid isn't the right
word maybe smart is a better word Trump
knows that if he gets on a debate stage
with the Sanderson and and Vivek it's
going to be bad for him just in terms of
he's already pulling at the top there's
no benefit and even if he does well it
only gives them more air time that makes
up my personal opinion is I think Vivek
ramaswamy would run circles around
DeSantis and Trump at the same time he
knows way more about this he's a fast
talker he's quick-witted he you know
Trump might you know Rama swampy over
here
I didn't come up with that by the way
someone else came up with that yeah but
it's still good but you know he'll he'll
do the insults and stuff of course look
man going up against Jeb Bush Ted Cruz
and like Rubio is not the same as
DeSantis and and ramaswamy so Trump
really should avoid that really should
avoid that if if I was advising Trump I
would say Do not debate these men you
will lose because there is nothing to
gain you're the big dog right you got a
40-point lead why do it and I'm saying
Trump could actually perform very well
but he just would not be able to perform
well enough to uh he would just lose he
could only lose from this so that's your
Council now what do you think he'll do
I think I don't know man it's tough
right because what you can go to him and
tell him like he probably shouldn't do
it you probably will because he loves
the stage oh yeah he loves a fight oh
and and maybe he's hearing this going
like then I have to beat him on the
stage then I have to do it if they think
I can it's not I it's not that I think
Trump can't win a debate with these men
it's that it's it's he's going up
against extremely competent individuals
who are going to you know who are going
to put weights on his ankles and you
already know the media is against him so
if you if he doesn't show up to these
debates how much negative ammunition
he's chicken he's scared remember like
Back to the Future like the one word you
couldn't call Michael J fox was what are
you yelling all of a sudden Trump scared
he's a chicken he's gonna you know he
Biden's not gonna debate either no he's
going to stay in the White House like
that's he's not going to come out I
think I'd like to see Biden debate RFK
Marianne Williamson I'd like to see that
I think I I think we're I think it's
we're in hot water negative territory if
Front Runners the incumbent president
and the former president just do not
debate whatsoever yeah I don't think
that's a good look for either candidate
I think what the media has done to RFK
and Marion Williamson is is disgusting
but you know obviously I hate the
corporate press so I despise them
they're evil people so that's that's not
shocking so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]